samedi soir france 2 a sorti le grand
jeu avec sa nouvelle émission le big
show présenté par un jarry qui nous
promettaient de grandes choses
l'émission assurément la plus folle du
service public
et tout ça au final pour se retrouver
passe à seven un peu bancal je faisais
enfants j'ai un petit garçon qui
s'appelle tinée petite fille s'appelle
vic j'adore les appelait dans la rue
victimes venaient là et des cadeaux spas
ou du tout
[Applaudissements]
alors que le principe était de
surprendre le public avec des jeux des
caméras cachées et même des happenings
avec des bébés pas du tout envie d'être
là
[Applaudissements]
mais bon heureusement qu'il leur restait
des effets spéciaux à couper le souffle
même si on sait tout ça qu'ils ont volé
l'idée paraît pas tout
[Musique]
alors guillaume tu sais que tu vas
écrire moi j'ai des surprises ce que
j'ai appris cette émission est un format
et ça ne peut pas être un format c'est
extrêmement fouillé ya pas de concept ya
pas de mécanique ya pas de rendez vous
tout semble le faut la séquence
feuillage de portable avec laëtitia
milot acheter comment ça je serai dans
le portable une célébrité enfin on n'y
croit pas une seconde et puis par
définition donc le concept j'appelle un
c'est de faire des surprises à des gens
qui sont dans le public mais on ne peut
pas les surprendre puisque ils savent
qu'ils vont être surpris c'est le
concept de l'émission donc franchement
je ne comprends pas comment une chaîne
comme france 2 peut acheter ça c'est pas
digne du service public on n'apprend
rien c'est pas drôle c'est pas
divertissant et le pop j'arrive c'est un
traquenard pour lui cette nation c'est
un traquenard là bien sûr il rit on est
dans un traquenard et c'est vrai que non
mais tu as et moi et divertissements de
france télévisions c'est c'est compliqué
que tu es toujours dit voilà c'est c'est
céder si ça ne savent pas faire ils
savent pas faire le meilleur directeur
des divertissements de france
télévisions
nicolas pernikoff tête avec son american
staff actuellement
l'ours qui était curieuse c'est qu'à un
moment il va dans le public il ya une
jeune femme je vous ai fait une surprise
en fait on le retrouve au lit chez elle
et après il lui fait tester les yeux
bandés un plateau c'est dégueulasse en
face à dire qu'un intérêt n'a rien
compris à ce que vous avez décrit du
salaire ça non ce que l'intérêt de
l'émission sur lui ce sont des
happenings comme ça des caméras cachées
etc
pour le moment il va dans le public il
ya quelqu'un qui est concerné ce soir
avancé qui alors on lèvent timidement le
droit une jeune femme et lui dit mais
vous savez que j'étais chez vous ben oui
j'étais chez vous mais ce qu'ils ont
filmée donc on les voit ensuite chez
elle effectivement les dents lié avec
son mari il l'a réveil est en fait le
seul à pique-niqué effet cédule porter
un plateau de poissons dégueulasse de
tourteaux et cetera qu'elle devait
reconnaître
c'est donc aucun intérêt gilbert n'est
pas pour moi big show se traduit
désormais par énorme d'aubin fait du
hand est dur le problème de l'émission
c'est sympa de faire des vannes ya pas
de concert hier matin patrick simon
casas désenvoûter ça sur tout ce qui se
fait ailleurs et yappa d'incarnation
alors que c'est le département met
d'ailleurs que animateur c'est un métier
et visiblement c'est pas celui déjà
rigueur et s'est dégonflé comme une
baudruche ce qu'on retiendra de big show
finalement c'est l'ampleur du naufrage
parce que toutes les séquences été raté
donc c'est une catastrophe et où il faut
arrêter jarrier oui arrêter le
divertissement sur dida il s il vous
plait ne me sucer pas parce que sinon je
vais ressortir vos sms de samedi soir
je suis battu maintenant je vais sortir
vous ne niez sortir beinheim
moi je trouve que c'est justement jarry
qui sort du lot et que l'émission c'est
moi il y avait un truc elle me faisait
penser à n'oubliez pas la brosse à dents
de maggie souvenez-vous de n'oublier pas
la brosse à dents de nagui ça va faire
un pain c'est signé je vous m'avez
répondu ça d'ailleurs et en fait c'était
justement extrêmement cadré et c est le
problème de cette émission c'était que
c'était fouillis et que donc on voyait
pas bien le concept mais moi en revanche
je dis que c'est jarry qui sort du lot
benjamin muller 7-6 franchement je
trouve que animateur c'est un vrai
métier alors jarry est un très bon
comics mais ils ont une france 2011 nous
lever les décès on prend des gens qui
ont travaillé avec des gens exactement
mais ils ont un secteur il doit la lui
les bonnes et influenceurs on va le
mettre à des mateurs banon ahly mateur
c'est pas ça l'huile est beau il est bon
comics il a un public comprend
animateurs ça ne fonctionne pas et
surtout on est il était un peu dans
l'émotion un peu dans l'animation il n'a
pas du tout tirer son show et
franchement c'est un naufrage et je
trouve ça un peu désobligeant pour les
animateurs de la chaîne de prendre des
gens extérieurs à qui son public et pas
et pète pas alors je vous dis en plus le
prix du beach aux ampoules 107-100 et
sandrine et comme le producteur de
l'émission c'était le même que celui de
la guerre il a dû se dire dans sa petite
tête j'essaie de faire de jarret un
nouveau la gaffe mais pareil c'est une
mauvaise idée parce que c'est ils ont
rien à voir tous les deux et je trouve
ça vraiment des amis dont le métier
d'animateur voilà je suis désolé pour
jari que j'aime beaucoup de mauron c'est
pas beau l'animateur est pas là pour toi
kelly alors moi ce qui la regarde et on
pas alors j'en pense pas grand chose je
vais vous dire la vérité mais par contre
ce que je peux dire c'est que ce que
j'aime quand même dans ce milieu c'est
qu'on rappelle des animateurs et des
vrais animateurs quand on a besoin
d'animateurs et justement on met pas en
porte-à-faux des gens qui ne sont pas
animateur et qui vont ensuite basso
voler le travail de quelqu'un d'autre
qui me veulent
juste
pour faire cette émission que votre
armée terme à sa mère en danger une
personne qui ne l'est pas comme jarry
qu'on aime beaucoup et au final on
pourrait mettre quelqu'un que cinq ans
c'est son travail c'est son travail et
il y en a assez pour voilà alors d'abord
je pense que la grèce ne peut pas
prendre parce qu'il faut arrêter de
prendre les gens pour des nigauds on
voit jarry dans ma stinger en train de
reconnaître une pieuvre ou je ne sais
pas où 1
et l'on retrouve la saison d'après dans
le big show donc moi en tant que
téléspectateur je suis perdu il est des
risettes sur tf1 et après il fait des
risettes sur france 2 il n'y a pas de
grille de lecture ensuite jean marc
généreux c'était pareil avec
spectaculaire en loyer dans d'assez la
saison d'après bout on retrouve un
spectaculaire ça marche pas ça permet à
prendre il ya qu'en termes d'identité
d'ailleurs il le dit voilà il le dit non
mais vous êtes bien sur france 2 donc
genre laval ah bah oui on n'est pas sur
tf1 et on comprend pas parce qu'on n'est
pas habitué enfin moi je trouve que dans
cap a une identité forte par rapport à
par rapport à jarry et ensuite pour ceux
qui ont vu jarry en spectacle jarrier
atypique excusez moi mais ça ressemble
exactement son spectacle et son one man
show à ce qu'il fait là malgré tout il
est comme ça dans l'empathie la nouvelle
décalée mais mme eliane à kiev jeudi
relève à craquer y aller busigny fait
rien c'est vraiment fou de joie donc
encore une fois peut-être que c'est pas
notre humour mais je vous assure en tant
que dans son humour ça marche bien bien
sûr mais le problème de l'émission
séquelles et fourre-tout elle est
bordélique on comprend pas il se
positionne pas très bien parfois donc
voilà c'est un peu le bordel à mon pull
il a bien réussi j'arrive son coup parce
qu'ils voulaient plus et moi j'ai dit si
vous voulez pu rester à tf1 tf1 parce
qu'il avait eu peur du coville et perdre
de l'argent du coup il est parti se
cacher à france 2 et france 2 lui a
donné l'animation moi je le big show
vous allez voir des trucs qui si
extraordinaire que vous avez jamais vu
nulle part allez dans un taxi faire une
caméra cachée j'ai vu chez nous c'est
adele et qui est parti faire dans un
taxi southwest le massage les vues la
chanson surprise avec amir je l' ai vu
aussi dans un karaoké j'ai tout vu aller
dans une maison on a pris les clés de
chez vous donc j'ai vu qu'il est temps à
quel moment il m'a surpris j'ai pas été
surpris une seule fois quand j'ai mis le
programme j'ai vu les masques sa mamie
non goise je voulais changer de c'est à
dire non plus la même année pauvre jean
van hamme et attend mais je me lance un
regard des démissions avec des masques
mais j'ai trouvé même ça bizarre j'ai
même été j'ai pu c'est là le
raisonnement plus loin en disant c'est
fait parce qu'à chaque fois que
quelqu'un venait parler il enlevait le
masque par réflexe mais on parlait avec
les masques avant on enlevait pas les
masques donc à et le dernier truc les
tice amelio laetitia milot je la dois
run sur le balcon j'ai pas compris
l'homme s'était kinshasa c'était quoi en
fait ce matin je me suis dit c'est comme
moi avec bernard montiel
c'est paris
c'est la mascotte moderne à monter ma
basse quoi sert il à 1,8 million donc si
tu n'as pas compris c'est pas bon
moi je connais rien j'étais derrière où
il avait fait 1,6 million la naître avec
sophie davant ils font pas ils vont pas
bon séjour les millions de jeux wii mais
pas non non non mais la raison alors
annoncé dans la loyauté sans faille
normalement sinistré ça vienne
s'expliquer ce que c'est que les gens
viennent plus parce que les hivers sont
tellement nuls son est bon que les gens
deviennent plus parce que ils sont
pleins guérison soyons honnêtes et vous
quand vous m'avez envoyé des sms moi
j'avais carrément oublié je me suis
remise de suspense divertissement c'est
le seul truc à travailler parce qu'ils
arrêtent ont réussi direction ce match
quand c'est d'aider les senlisiens même
si mais c'est vrai que le divertissement
c'est un gros problème à france
télévisions c'est le seul problème voilà
deux du groupe après après le reste
c'est vrai qu'ils ont tous réussi les
jeux ça marche très fort la fiction
c'est un énorme carton le sport on n'en
parle même pas c'est vrai que c'est un
carton sur france 2 tout art tonnes sauf
celle-là faut s'y marier
avec laurent ruquier qui couperait abbas
à
savoir d'où ils cent mille paraître dans
un taxi faire une camille
800 mille cent mille euros est-ce que je
peux danser la location du terrain
peut-être non mais ça n'en fait ses
missions mais pourquoi faire céder tous
tu sais un petit peu non non non mais
vous savez je suis franchement ras le
lundi ce n'est pas parce que je voulais
écrire samedi on s'est échangé des
textos et c'est vrai que quand vous
faites un prime ou fait jusqu'à un
million jusqu'à deux millions deux pour
abuser qui est cinq fois moins supérieur
assaillants non non non c'est pas
simplement là là c'est là c'est plus que
cinq tours et votre sac est dix fois
moins je vous dis oui mais voilà la cour
des comptes la rentabilité ont donné il
faut quand même que je sais pas quand
mais ce kiss-in dans une émission sur
france 2 à 1 3 me lancer à 800 cc c'est
énorme et
c'est n'importe quoi en fait la chaîne
ils ont tout fait à l'envers ils se sont
pas dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme
émission novatrice ils sont dit on va
prendre jarry on va lui faire faire
n'importe quoi ça sert à chauffer cet
argent 6 au niveau des chaînes parce que
sur les grandes chaînes comme tf1 ou
france 2 en ce moment je trouve qu'ils
mettent n'importe quoi en frais en prime
mécaniquement ça fait un million de
millions parce que de toute façon il ya
des gens devant ces chaînes et vous
mettez ça sur ces 8 sur w9 sur tmc mais
ça fait 150
personnes et ça les gens viennent
mécaniquement vous avez toujours un
minable qui ont été faits sur ce futur
ya un million 500 m c'est sur ces 8 ou
sur nrj luz et c'est l'exigence pour les
grandes chaînes elle a baissé mais ya
dix ans jamais on aurait mis sans quoi
ils acceptent ça alors il
peut faire un truc mais aussi on savait
qu il faut quand même souligner que
c'est un concept donc britannique
effectivement et c'est encore les
anglais
encore les anglais sans déconner sur bbc
n'a pourtant cessé les anglais sur bbc
one la dernière émission a fait 8
millions et alors la façon d'animer du
lait qui s'appelle michael mcintyre
tactique différente lui c'est un grand
show men un effort jarre il est génial
sauf que l'autre anglais il est très
sérieux trésor la rigueur t il ya un
truc il ya c'est un fourre tout un tas
d'émissions la façon présentée est très
différente et elle cartonne une lampe
état de santé qui revoit sa façon c'est
clair sachez qu'ils ont déjà enregistré
une autre émission il y en a deux et
leurs invités le premier c'était amir ce
sera obispo